[Music]
hey
we meet again welcome back september
2020 is here to slap us in the face
with tons of new games and dlcs it's
also the time of year where sports games
hit their annual release dates
i'm going to miss those if that's okay
and focus on new ips
returning masterpieces and a free game
too so let's do this
i'm starting with wwe 2k battlegrounds
this is hugely different from the annual
game we usually receive
this is because that series is taking a
year off and 2020
is when we get this over-the-top arcade
game
featuring more than 70 superstars and
when i say ott
i mean it there's a gator at ringside
you can drop a car on someone's head
the campaign mode stars paul heyman as
we become a wwe rookie
and unlock custom items and take down
the legends you've watched as a child
the game uses a currency system which is
gained by completing challenges
or going online in tournaments and that
feeds back into the cycle of vanity
items
if you ever wanted a wwe themed super
smash bros
i think this is the closest we're going
to get to that
releasing on september 18th on ps4 xbox
one pc
and twitch oh and stadia 2. i'll be
playing this one on the gameplay channel
as soon as i get my hands on it
and i challenge you to some online
shenanigans
[Music]
the next game has the potential to be
something we play for years
marvel's avengers hopefully by now you
either played the beta or you've seen
the game running for long enough to
notice
marvel's avengers is a game as a service
in the same vein as the brilliant
destiny
or the less brilliant anthem set in
third person we take control of the
avengers
and one day there will be so many of
these you'll have palpitations trying to
decide who to take on each mission
but until then the group is quite small
on release day
the story revolves around the aftermath
of a day and the death of captain
america
and the breakup of the avengers we'll
piece the team back together and take on
the combined might of aim
and modoc and here's the thing to note
right away games like this
usually have content issues early on
like i said there's only a small number
of avengers available right away
but more are coming all the time
similarly in six months from now the
added missions from all these avengers
will evolve the game greatly right now i
have to say the story missions are great
fun
especially the detail in the backstories
they're staggeringly good but the
multiplayer is where most of the action
will take place
and it seems to be a rinse and repeat
kind of content where we
replay the same missions multiple times
and that's fine for some people
but for others that will wear thin
quickly the game is designed for four
people to play together online
but you don't have to do that if you
prefer to do this alone you can set up
the ai to take control of your team
or just do it all on your todd no
pressure at all here
i plan to be covering this game in depth
and we'll try to let you know everything
you need to know before you buy the game
on september the 4th on ps4 xbox one pc
and stadia and another thing to note is
that marvel's avengers will include a
free update to the next gen hardware
which is nice are you old
like me and remember 2002 and the game
mafia
well back then it was mind-blowing and
later this month
mafia is remade which could explode our
brain cells once again
mafia definitive edition takes the
original story of 1930s crime families
and expands it we play as tommy angelo
who joins the salieri
organization and slowly climbs the ranks
as you'd expect from a game like this
it's just like gta a completely open map
with incidental events occurring with
npcs
who have nothing to do with the story
you've heard it before but the living
breathing environment is what brings us
towards these games and the impact of
gta is definitely felt as the series has
evolved over the last 18 years
the game will feature more dense
environments such as taller buildings to
better represent that time period
as well as areas like chinatown will now
be more distinctive and recognizable
right away
the og game back in 2002 was given a 9.2
out of 10 by
ign so everything about this remake is
set on solid ground
are you gonna dive in and become the mob
enforcer i know i am
september the 25th mafia definitive
edition drops on ps4 xbox
one and pc
[Music]
another game rebuilt from the pits of
nostalgia is none other than tony hawk's
pro skater one
and two back in 1999 this time and 2000
these games introduced the world of
non-skaters to the brilliance of
skateboarding
the 2020 version smashes both games
together and completely updates the
game's engine
to look and feel modern the majority of
the killer soundtrack
has returned with 37 new tracks thrown
in for good measure
tony hawk's pro skater 1 and 2 features
online multiplayer to allow you to take
on your friends
and the designer mode is here to keep
the game thriving for years
design your own tracks and challenges to
test the skills of others
with 19 base levels there's no rush to
make your own tracks but it's nice to
know it's there for the future
tony hawk's pro skater one on two
releases on september the 4th
on ps4 xbox and pc and if you don't like
it
tell your parents chances are they will
be over the moon to hear about this game
and now the free game of the month
rocket league the arcade football
slash soccer rocket car extravaganza
i brought this to your attention last
month as the release date was summer
2020
and guess what that's still the same
date right now so the best i can do is
tell you when summer officially ends
which is september the 22nd so that will
be the last day you can expect rocket
league to become free to play
but it could drop any day now the
suspense is killing me
expect the game to attempt to grab your
cash via rocket passes
those as you already know are rocket
league's version of the infamous battle
pass from many battle royale games
featuring vehicles trails and a whole
bunch of vanity items
any guesses on the release date let's
see who can guess this right
i really should be talking about the
sports sims now and their annual
releases but i'd rather tell you about a
piece of dlc content for a game you may
have missed
the game is the outer worlds and the dlc
is peril of gorgon
i don't feel like this game got the
attention it fully deserved in 2019
hands down this is the best fallout
style game ever made
the sci-fi rpg with a multitude of
endings and playstyles
i lowkey murderized everyone i met to
see if i could rule the galaxy alone
but there are other ways to play i'm
told diplomacy is a good option
yeah right the next expansion peril of
gorgon brings the planet of gorgon to
the game filled with new npcs quest
lines
armor and weaponry september the 9th if
you're interested
on ps4 xbox and pc and as we're talking
about dlc here's a free piece of new
content for another great game
untitled goose game the game in which we
wreak havoc on a small village
check out this free update a co-op mode
will be available on september 23rd
now you and a buddy can team up and
cause even more mischief
this may not be a world shattering
update but added co-op modes in games
should always be celebrated i'm going
gonna be jumping back in
so there we have it seven games that
should grab your attention in september
2020
hopefully there is something for
everyone in this bunch my hopes
are for the marvel's avengers game to
grow into a great experience
and the wwe battleground looks like a
good way to live out my rey mysterio
fantasies
i'm adam from playstation grenade and if
you've got this far into the video tell
me who your favorite wrestler is
i already know it's jake this nate
robert right see you soon
[Music]